es sickert wohl offensichtlich etwas
durch unser Kollege Stefan Kulle scheint
zu wissen welcher Name zumindest
gehandelt wird Stefan stimmt das ist da
was dran wissen Sie was
ja also das was ich jetzt sagen kann ist
natürlich mit Vorbehalt aber ich weiß
jetzt dass es sich um Josef Kardinal
Ratzinger handelt der der neue Papst ist
das ist die Nachricht die ich gerade
bekommen habe
ich bin ganz aufgeregt Herr Kollege
jetzt haben sie aber hier im Studio in
Bonn vier Kinder nach unten fallen sehen
ich frage ich frage ganz vorsichtig ist
diese Meldung ist diese Nachricht
belastbar oder sind das Gerüchte das ist
eine sehr sichere Nachricht die eben
gerade von einer halben Minute bei mir
eingeht ist
[Applaus]
liebe Brüder und Schwestern
der brothers and sisters
[Applaus]
annunzio wo bist Gaudium
sang der Romane Iglesia
kardinalem Ratzinger
[Applaus]
wir sind groß
[Musik]
großen Papst Johannes Paul dem zweiten
[Applaus]
bescheidenen Arbeiter im Weinberg des
Herrn
me Controller in fato
dass der Herr
weiß auch mit unzulänglichen
Instrumenten zu addieren und ich
erbitte eure Gebete für mich
[Applaus]
resorto in der Freude des
wiederauferstehen
erstandenen Herrn und
treu seinem Glauben werden wir handeln
der Herr wird mir helfen und die heilige
Maria wird mir zur Seite stehen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
wir kommen zum
segenprotestet autoritate konfitius
ypsyntonobi
er hatte Michaelis erkancelli Beate
Johannes
baptistenorum Petrit pauli
it omnium sanktorum
miseriators
jesus Christus hat vitametherme
[Musik]
Absolution im Remission im
omnium-pecatorium vistorum spatiums
IT Imitation im vite
Gracia mit Konstellation im Sand ist
Spiritus
it Finale im persevarancia in Ponys
operibus trieb dort wo bist um die
Potenz edmission
[Musik]
Spiritus sankti dich in der zuckerwusst
at man ja simple
[Musik]
[Applaus]